Speaker 1: I have some unbelievable video to show
you of a Missouri state senator asking a 14 year
old transgender girl about her genitals. And as
vile and disgusting as this video is, this is
state senator from Missouri. Eileen, I'm sorry,
Elaine. Elaine Gannon speaking to 14 year old
trans girl Avery Jackson. Whatever your view is
about trans bathrooms or sports or whatever. Can
we all agree that this line of questioning is not
only disgusting, but it also completely exposes
the ignorance of the state senator about
trans issues? Let's take a look at this.
Speaker 4: We were in the ladies room and you
realize somebody else was in there. This doesn't
have a female, has a male body instead of a female
body. I mean, it just causes some issues. There
is a lot of people go to the bathroom,
and it's probably going to realize that
you think that the reason you have this
Speaker 1: long hair. Now, did you guys
understand that it's that it's almost genius,
it's inadvertently genius, the state senator
says, you know, it's really a problem. You've
got a girls room, and then all of a sudden someone
goes in and they've got a male body part, right?
And it causes a lot of problems and confusion.
And the 14 year old trans girl goes,
No, because nobody realizes what's going
on. You're not checking out genitals. And
the state senator goes. Well, people probably
don't realize that you are biologically male
because you have long hair. Now the brilliance of
this is this is the entire point. It nobody knows.
It doesn't matter. Nobody is affected by
things they're not aware of. They're not
checking genitals in the bathroom. And she looks
like a girl for lack of a better term. So she say,
Well, people don't even realize it. So then what
is the problem? The tree falls in the woods and
nobody hears it that it really make a noise,
does it make a noise or, you know, whatever,
if you've got a trans girl in the bathroom
and it looks like nobody is paying particular
attention to the genitals and
nobody's eyebrows were raised,
then what are we even really talking about here?
Speaker 4: Are you going to do the procedure? I
don't know where else or someone
will set you back more. Do you want
to do is not let you do that. Your whole
argument here is the fact that you don't
bring people back, Obama. No one.
No one is looking at the ground.
I was seriously just curious.
Unidentified: On Riker's Island
Speaker 4: and getting people to
see that happening right now best. We are in
seven years time while people understand. I
know this is not my place. I don't mind
exposing themselves in one place for us
right now is and getting wrapped up in families
and bathrooms. So also not any dehumanization.
Speaker 1: So you guys get the point. State
senator wanting to know what are your genitals
and do you plan to get the ones that are the
fundamental? So there's two things that go
on here. One is a fundamental misunderstanding of
sort of like what goes on in bathrooms that that's
number one. And that's been we've we've been aware
of that for years. But number two, it's also sort
of the blowing up of small pieces of this entire
issue of just treating people with dignity and
respect and kind of moving on to solving the real
problems we have in society. Trans sports, as I've
said before. Are there questions to just like
figure out about about trans transports? Yeah,
it's fine. There's leagues that deal with that.
And sure, figure it out. But it's not really the
main issue when it comes to the issue of trans
rights and transphobia. The bathroom thing again
when we look at is this really a problem?
Are these predators that they say will just
be lurking everywhere? If all of a sudden people
are able to use the bathroom that matches their
gender identity? It just doesn't happen. It's not
actually a problem and just a very, very vile line
of questioning here. If you're just listening,
we'll have all these clips up on our Instagram.
And you can let me know your thoughts on this by
finding me on Twitter at Packman. The David Pakman
show is, of course, a viewer supported program
that depends counts on your membership support.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com. It's the
new hot thing it really is. You can use the coupon
code Wow 22. If you would like a discount
off of a membership at join Pacman dot com.